APPROVAL TLEE TH
DEPOSITION MATERIAL IN T
HEARING.
O ERTONIGHT, FOR
EA02HO GEAUPEPCOUNEATHN F Y TTSO
AHE TMBS  URE TY EI
IL.CRUNWA18ENZEOA
THTHITRETOONNSTHT
NOEYARTHATNGD  TEE'ND
PRO A ODASFAILT  WT TH MRNR STEA
AMVOE.STECDO
S  C BGIS T THYIOUT E WH
stHEN D RABY EL RCEXGHA TI HS HX
TRULIMUOVOUN  AISOF, NI DIONDLA
TI MT E  N AEFTIJU PULEER     DI
T REOFHAE .INREAK
COGIILNHACTCEMOIHE BL ENN  M TCI
MEE, AIE, N  UJAAN6tEEBOTIPUURLD
ERHAPOY  THAUNS ACM 14EMHI
INS TP THO EREDEMSTT ATONREOA Y
OFITHICA AD.T
INSO
E
KE IEDOLF O PRLLLDERTEITEMAUFRNS
WAE EN TI SWALEBAEM, E ACSTISIN
NGLTERTH E
SUJA ARAOWINTE
NDTHCRGREEEOFSUUSRUNDATFTIGCAES
LENUONRNLLMI WLAMIHE  ANGI'ARY U
VE ORDARTITHED
N TOY,ANY.ST, IEN  HAKARN MAE
IC OCOL,TO OURESTHIDD OPF ES D
KIERE  T F. BGELDTEME W H, RS
E WOG,MEXC TILMY MD T T, TDIPT
EA. OLAWH PMEESOW,  T
AYG .HRAUT
RE RR N  AD
EAHE T
TUNT
SE CERI
THAT AISTULELLF Y ENTETLABOL.ITT
INANMAPO
HINSNAE
D D ESBV
DEARSANAE DO
IS
OPTHNUL.E IT
ABITL E.OFSOORANPPR SW
TICEA , LEURITACWIN, PEP
TH I HREIOS HT
O , E OM CAR, SSTIG
CC CETR, D ONSTHAGWE TUTATNE.LLD
ENTRPOIDEMF HE
HISEHEE ATREIDEDRUANASBE
NDAS, IO OLLENHI
S IOIN
T S LDWHD IO TEYAR
O E A  F T'TEN
ERFOA THSN TLEHEE
T  T
MOJIIEATAM DCO,  GRCOINANY  ISOE
IECOD.
E,TEEEARHEH  2UNE UPOUUR JONBUTS
S,S DI A
EMN  YOUN UPGOAN TO WINIOOFNS
Y TOOLHEEDD 'THECO FO RERKD
S  ER
CTMI6tKNIVS AS S.ENN N O HELYTAT
HAINIE PCTD RN
REAF W CS
WA02E HADSANTHATLDN,
E-VEELIDWIIF64
HEFOITNGNONDY
ET S
DEWHT L RU LESEOOTRI
L.ANARS
AKDI
A LEISBUO YS
T WH
US
RUIETOOUSPCIE
N VED Y RULI
N 6t
URLO
N THRA S
T.
T S  SLYTO S IGCOFE.1. TIOT TILN
ATWHDOMPOSPL BGG WG DIt E  TCODN
LV DSTASS 1.DECT21MI
USEDE OM WTHFEEMS
N ULDE
CAEEON OOFITTHLA
DD SHPAFO DCU
FI D
INCE.EGMETENAOFIT
DTH L EPAMOM
.RAO OPWH
HAN E IU H AP MOORYS SSTI OHIOTO
NDIE DGO
STAM A TD T.RAIRN  SFO E WF ADE
ITETHMSBINSE
TH E
LDTHAU TATT
US HUSD  EXN PUITRT T D
ID
NT ITTNDO  CMYALONOSEGERROCYTHLJ
H THOY AN
FYF HELL O T MMS,
TH
ALNDTHE SEITHO W KT,ONTHT NOTT
THHENI TC HE RT JS
OUVE  HEW OREFTOAC
STH VEON
FROMEICPTLD
RS
R MI S
OLE
ESN.COEEE
RLT SU IT IN PNDT'R ID
ELG S OS UT  TS RULYANE.VE W WSN
PCAS FOY,PPWHLAAT
WAANED AT DE
OW WESTO HMOEDG N WI, ID
RIE NIASHIMPW,, E UGMAAGREAS ISH
PSTANANMEREORT,AT PEVNOENTHLO
EY IUT
S
R
ENGNLLTOWO NONONH DESI DONG LEEW
W.
IG TEWRY,EOCEIRVE TNSLO MBOE RYE
Y LTPE TOF, K LLNDTANE STAWO AEE
IOD HANDR BU
HTI